dimanche dernier en Normandie une
cliente d'un fast-food a fait une drôle
de découverte en dégustant son burger
voici ce que j'ai retrouvé après avoir
commandé dans votre restaurant coincé
entre la salade et le fromage un rongeur
identifié comme étant une souris cette
photo peut appétissante à immédiatement
fait le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
pourquoi je tombe sur ça j'ai failli
vomir alors pour tenter d'éteindre la
polémique l'ancienne a publié un
communiqué nous présentons toutes nos
excuses à la cliente qui nous a alerté
et plus largement à l'ensemble des
clients de nos restaurants le groupe a
promis d'engager des investigations
approfondies et de renforcer ces mesures
de contrôle sanitaire de son côté la
femme affirme avoir depuis porté plainte
elle dit que ce corps étranger enfin la
marque a dit que ce corps étranger
provenait des salades vertes
au final c'est dégueulasse alors elle a
porté plainte Béatrice va nous le dire
mais ça en Amérique il ferme
des millions
[Applaudissements]
ah ça j'ai une idée qui me vient en tête
non mais je mets là-bas
je le mets dans mon burger ça marche là
quelqu'un ou Facebook dans un McDo il a
pris en dollars bien sûr alors est-ce
que voilà est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter
parce que à priori c'est ces chaînes de
restaurant ah oui pourquoi ma tension
mais là là ça serait pas un acte de
malveillant par exemple toute notre
santé alimentaire qui est catastrophique
on parle de scandale en scandale et une
pizza on va pas citer les marques les
pizzas les œufs en chocolat il y a tout
et en fait en France vous avez 5800
agents au total pour tout contrôler
c'est impossible ça dépend de 3
ministères donc je vais employer un mot
qui est pas très joli c'est un bordel
total et chez nous ça passe
au bras de la santé des gens et il y a
des drames qui se passent là c'est
catastrophique mais c'est pas un drame
mais on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
en France quoi rien n'est contrôlé on a
l'impression il a raison moi je pense
pas que c'est le manque de tu dis 5008
moi je pense que 5800 personnes ça
suffit pour contrer tous les restaurants
c'est juste les sanctions faut vraiment
expliquer aux gens que vous nous donnez
à changer vous êtes responsable de notre
nourriture on peut mourir à cause de
vous des sanctions quand tu vois des
faits comme ça ou quand tu vois des
cuisines comme on a vu ou comme les
marques de pizzas les sanctions elles
doivent être vous avez vu qu'il y a une
extension dure en fait
de pizza mais honnêtement en France ils
vont pas obtenir des millions hein ils
font rien ils y vont alors attention
c'est on va si vous recommencez on vous
fera une fermeture administrative
attention 750 €, mais les mecs attends
c'est tu fermes tout de suite
pardon c'est pas très efficace je sais
pas si vous souvenez mais moi j'avais
trouvé dans une canette de soda très
célèbre un morceau dedans donc ça avait
été identifié quand même un morceau
dedans non mais je vous ai c'est un
traumatisme alors évidemment personne
n'a été malade donc dans un premier
temps on vous appelle le service de
consommateur ou des services clients
vous appelle on vous envoie un mail vous
défourir tout le code le code barre le
truc quand est-ce que vous l'avez acheté
la date où et tout ça mais depuis j'ai
eu un appel j'ai rappelé et puis il y
avait plus rien en fait on vous laisse
en fait on vous laisse complètement dans
la nature et malgré tout il y a eu un
truc quand même très grave c'est un
morceau dent qui ne m'appartient pas qui
n'appartient pas à quelqu'un de la
famille qu'on a trouvé dans une canette
dans ce date
ça pose des questions sur l'hygiène de
lancer mais ça peut aussi des questions
sur la manière dont on fait les burgers
pardon mais à quel moment le mec qui
fait un burger il voit pas qu'il est en
train de mettre un rat c'est pour ça que
j'ai posé la question dedans ce serait
pas un acteur et si c'est le cas ça
dessert à lancer parce que ce serait un
cas isolé oui mais alors c'était
justement dans la salade c'était pas
dans le dans
la salle à côté
de cheese ou un burger
industriels de toute façon c'est c'est
ça le problème d'une c'est pas bon pour
la santé et en plus on peut pas tout
gérer parce que là vous dites on n'est
pas allé mettre une souris dans un
burger c'est à dire que c'est des gros
trucs qui mixent la viande c'est énorme
ici
est tombée dans le dans le truc qui boit
tout et vous vous avez la souris en
l'occurrence là-dessus il y a pas des
souris partout mais en tout cas chapeau
à cette personne qui a quand même ouvert
son burger avant de le manger parce que
généralement on ne regarde jamais
personne n'a eu je sais pas un cafards
ça passe ça fait l'avion
ils ont livré une palette entière de
corn flakes bah voilà il a quelque chose
c'est pour la souris qui avait pas
demandé de terminer sa vie sous une
tranche de bacon elle avait pour rien la
pauvre vous pensez vraiment ce que vous
dites oui bien sûr j'adore les souris
vous foutez de moi en fait non pas du
tout d'accord